das ist gerade schwierig in ordnung oder
die schmerzen
ich war zwei stunden in der schule wenn
es gut lief und danach bin ich um 11 uhr
mittags vormittags eingeschlafen bin
erst am nächsten tag wieder aufgemacht
[Musik]
besser ab und kann mich damit umgehen
wenn ich über menschenleere dass die
keine panikattacken davor bekommen die
erde
und auch die konsistenz ganz gut
wenn wir von aktuell 0 5 bis 1 prozent
betroffenen kindern und jugendlichen
sprechen wird allein über die masse der
akute infektion eine nicht unerhebliche
zahl von longbow witt post cupid
patienten zu erwarten seien
[Musik]
robin stier ist oberarzt in der reha
klinik für kinder und jugendliche in
wangen mit sorge sieht er zunehmend
patientinnen und patienten mit problemen
nach einer krone erkrankung wie die 15
jährige natalie
habe ich immer noch nebenwirkungen ich
kann es manchmal keine treppen steigen
und danach ausarten zu sein oder ich bin
immer total müde und mir ist kalt und
ich habe eigentlich durchgehend
kopfschmerzen also während der
erkrankung habe ich fast den ganzen tag
geschlafen
ich habe kurz essen gemacht und dann bin
ich auch
finanzamt ali ist seit einem halben jahr
krank sie kann sich nur 20 minuten lang
konzentrieren ihr leben ist schwieriger
und einsamer geworden
[Musik]
ein ganz anderes leben quasi hat aber
man kann wirklich langsam damit umgehen
also es wird noch mal ich weiß jetzt wie
ich atmen kann wie ich damit umgehe wenn
ich über menschenleere dass ich keine
panikattacken davor gekommen das ist
halt ganz gut trotzdem ist es nicht weg
und trotzdem das ist immer noch blöd
[Musik]
auch die 17 jährige emilie leidet unter
den folgen ihrer corona infektion die
symptome werden vermutlich durch eine
überreaktion des immunsystems verursacht
die jugendlichen setzen große hoffnungen
in die reha und die möglichkeiten hier
in der klinik
ziel der reha maßnahmen ist den beiden
jugendlichen die teilhabe am täglichen
leben wieder zu ermöglichen
zurück zu kehren in die familie in die
schule um einen therapieplan für die
zwei zu erstellen sind noch
untersuchungen nötig heute eine
lungenfunktionsprüfung
hast du gut gefrühstückt
ich hatte mal ein komplettes leben
endlich durch getan was ich machen
möchte ich habe schon ganz sagen
einplanen und auf einmal war der
komplette plan einfach ich konnte nicht
in die schule gehen ich konnte mein
hobby ist nicht mehr nachgehen ich bin
eigentlich tänzerin das konnte ich nicht
mehr machen ich hab eigentlich
den ganzen tag im bett ich war zwei
stunden in der schule wenn es gut lief
und danach bin ich um 11 uhr mittags
vormittags eingeschlafen bin erst am
nächsten tag wieder aufgewacht es war
eigentlich nicht mehr möglich
die prüfung unter belastung soll
aufschluss über die leistungsfähigkeit
ihrer lunge geben
aber nach wenigen minuten auf dem
laufband hat emily ihre grenze erreicht
sie hat atemnot und bekommt angst
richtig wirklich gut gemacht
nach tief einatmen ausatmen
du kriegst bin wegen der aus stoff haben
wir gesehen brauchst du keine sorgen
machen ob es kommt genügend luft rein
mag sich lieber hinsetzen einmal kurz
kommt nicht einmal am besten hier
hinsetzen okay
das kann das schwierig machen oder die
schmerzen
weiter
ich würde sagen das schlimmste ist nicht
mal all diese symptome zu haben sondern
das gefühl zu haben dass niemand einen
wirklich versteht und dass man quasi das
gefühl hat allein zu sein damit und auch
sie das allen deinem umfeld quasi wieder
gesund werden dass man in der klasse
leute sich die krone haben und wieder
gesund werden und das gefühl zu haben es
ist alles gemein weil man selber nicht
gesund wird aber alle im umfeld schon
okay dass ich nochmal ab robin stier
kann emily beruhigen von jetzt anstehen
achtsamkeit schonendes training und viel
geduld auf dem programm
vier wochen später
[Musik]
natalie und emily haben inzwischen einen
vollen tagesplan beim schwertkampf
schulen die beiden ihre konzentration
und denen gleichzeitig die
atemmuskulatur
man merkt dass ich ein bisschen
belastbarer bin dass ich nicht jedes mal
mittagsschlaf machen muss dass ich mehr
ausgehe dass ich mir mit menschen machen
weil vorher war ich sehr viel in meinem
zimmer nur und hier lerne ich auch
wieder mehr kontakt zu menschen
aufzunehmen und mehr zu machen einfach
über den ganzen tag verteilt
am nachmittag steht den beiden eine
besondere prüfung bevor
heute haben wir wieder eine einheit wo
wir speziell auf die geruchs und
geschmacks thematik eingehen dort geht
es viel darum die verschiedenen
geschmäcker in der jeweiligen
lokalisation zu erschmecken und sich
vorher auch überlegen rieche ich schon
was bevor ich was schmecke
eine scheibe und guckt mal auch ihr
unterschied
ein test ob der geruchs- und
geschmackssinn zurückkommen
[Musik]
die erde
ok und auch die konsistenz ganz komisch
finde ich auch erde
schon irgendwas hat so ich glaube dass
er die konsistenz als tagesschau werde
ihr sagen bitte gerne oder einfach nur
so so neutrale er
rauche gern
vielleicht wird schokolade nie wieder
wie früher schmecken aber emily und
natalie lernen langsam mit longo witt
umzugehen man sollte auf jeden fall
müssen dass die krankheit nicht
innerhalb von 2-3 monaten einfach wieder
gut wird oder dass man wenn man reha
kommt man kann nicht erwarten dass es
danach einfach wieder gut dass man nach
einfach gesund wird das wäre nicht so
sein und das ist uns glaube ich auch
allen bewusst es ist eine krankheit die
man eben noch nicht erforscht man weiß
nicht ob sie jetzt in zwei monaten oder
in zwei jahren weg sein wird und man
braucht die geduld man muss sich selber
die zeit geben
in den vier wochen im allgäu sind
nathalie und emily vor allem
selbstbewusster geworden beide haben um
weitere vier wochen verlängert
[Musik]
ich möchte aber noch von schwester
werden gerade weil ich jetzt so lange
krank waren weil es so viel zeit in
krankenhäusern oder bei ärzten verbracht
habe ich immer mehr gemerkt wie sehr das
es was ich machen möchte und auch wenn
es jetzt noch ein jahr länger laut oder
dann auch zwei je nachdem mir ist hier
bewusst geworden dass es einfach nur
darum geht gesund zu werden und dass das
das wichtigste ist
mein plan ist es wahrscheinlich dass ich
die zehnte klasse noch mal wiederholen
werde auf einer anderen schule um dann
später architektur zu studieren
und falls das nicht klappen sollte
möchte ich gerne modedesign studieren
ich habe während meiner erkrankung war
sie angefangen kleider zu nähen ich
hatte nämlich nicht mehr die kraft
wirklich aus dem haus zu gehen und das
konnte ich dann etappenweise zu hause
selber machen
ärzte die kämpfen jugendliche die
zweifeln viele junge menschen sind
betroffen und für einige wird es
vielleicht nie mehr so sein wie früher
[Musik]